so that leaves us with our golden
medalist who is Wednesday
Lindsey st. Pierre and Ashley Graham
with their film D a deal as Marcus
Lindsey and Ashley Wow this is just this
is amazing we want to thank everybody at
the Academy this is just speechless this
is a wonderful honor but first off we
want to get down to business and
introduce our third creator Kate
Reynolds thank you
it's incredible all throughout the
production of our film the faculty at
our school kept telling us how much they
enjoyed our story and they kept giving
us the advice not to screw it up and
well I guess we didn't so the thank-yous
we'd like to thank our faculty advisor
Heather Heather Thompson our pre-pro
instructor Paul downs our art instructor
John DaVinci and all of the other
faculty at Ringling College of Art and
Design as well as our wonderful
classmates who helped us along the way
we'd like to thank our composer Cory
Wallace our sound designer Mauricio Dory
and everybody who supported our
Kickstarter and of course we'd like to
thank our family our friends and our
parents for supporting us the entire way
again we want to thank everyone for
loving our film as much as we do and
giving us such an incredible week thank
you